>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
[ Silence ]
>> Mary Jane Deeb: Good afternoon
ladies and gentlemen and welcome
to the African Mid East Division.
I am Mary Jane Deeb,
Chief of the division
and I'm delighted to
see you all here.
This is a very special
program we're bringing back
to the library some
of the people we love.
And Ms. Tambra Raye
Stevenson is one of the people
who have done a great deal in her
life and has contributed in her work
to a better understanding
of a region
for which this division
is responsible for Africa.
And she would share her thoughts
and her ideas with you in a moment.
Before this, before
we get into the meat
of the program I always do a
little commercial for this division
and highlight the fact
that we are responsible
for seventy eight countries
in the world.
We're responsible for the whole
continent of Africa, sub-Saharan,
North Africa and the Middle
East and the Hebraic world.
So there are three sections, the
Hebraic section which connects
from the whole world in Hebrew
and Yiddish like you know.
The Near East section which extends
to another already the Arab world,
Turkey and Iran but also
Central Asia and the Caucuses.
And as I mentioned Africa
is the whole continent,
we collect in the vernacular,
we serve people here
in the reading room
and we do programs
and conferences and exhibits.
And concerts, sometimes we show
films as well and we invite scholars
to come and share with them
the research and the work
and the work they're doing.
So that we are all kept up to date
with the developments in the region
and that we help our patrons
also get a better understanding
for the culture, for the
society, for the history.
And today is a case in point so
Miss Stevenson will be talking
about a very important aspect
of culture which is food.
And food is not only to feed
the body, to keep us going
but it has a great
many other implications
and she will share with us.
Our division is also made up
researchers of the specialists
who help the researchers
and they are the ones
who are responsible
for these programs.
And so today Eve Ferguson
who is a reference librarian
in the African section
has organised this program
and will introduce the speaker.
So Eve.
[ Silence ]
>> Eve Ferguson: Good afternoon.
I'm glad to see you all
here today on what promise
to be a really horribly rainy day,
but as my speaker who will come
up has said when you're on a
mission the weather cooperates
and obviously it did,
it stopped raining.
So, what can I say about Tambra
Raye Stevenson that I'm not going
to read right now except to say
that she is perhaps the most
dynamic young woman I know.
Always comes up with new
ideas, always doing something
and when I saw little WANDA I
fell in love with little WANDA.
She is a wonderfully cute
little character based
on a wonderfully cute little girl.
I'll let my speakers say more
about how little WANDA came about
and I just love the mission and I
said, you know, this is something
that we need to let
the world know about.
Well, before I did a flyer or
anything she had tweeted it
out to everybody and
it went all over
and I understand we're
on Facebook live now.
So, I love the way the younger
generation uses social media
to get the word out, you don't
necessarily have to be here.
Of course if you're not here
you're not going to get any
of the light refreshments
that we're to serve later.
So, that can't be Facebook
lived but everything else can
and before I read my introduction I
just want to get everybody in here
to wish Miss Tambra Raye
Stevenson a happy birthday.
It's not today it was about a week
and a half ago but close enough.
It's in the month of September and
so happy birthday Tambra, you know,
I know that there are
great things ahead for you.
Now I'll read her bio.
Miss Stevenson is the 2014 National
Geographic travel of the year.
An author of the forthcoming
Where's WANDA book series
which creates the first girl
character exploring Africa
through its foods and female
farmers to help heal her community.
As founder and CEO of Women
Advancing Nutrition Dietetics
in Agriculture because WANDA is
not just a name, it's an acronym.
She supports equitable
opportunities for women and girls
and to improve their communities
through food and nutrition.
As founder of native soul
kitchen she educates, advocates
and advocates for preserving
the health of Africa and beauty
of African food through
lectures and workshops.
And of course you can
learn more about WANDA
at I am WANDA dot org
and native soul dot com.
I know that upcoming WANDA
is got lots of exciting trips
that she's going on and so
without any further I do I want
to introduce my friend and I'll
repeat defender not offender
because she defends the health of
the African diaspora community.
So please welcome Tambra
Raye Stevenson.
[ Audience Clapping ]
>> Tambra Raye Stevenson: So
it's such a great pleasure
to be back here at the African
and Middle Eastern reading room.
I definitely see you all as
dear friends who enjoy good food
and also history as I do.
So, I want to start off with a small
video that I actually had prepared
that kick started Where's WANDA
through a crowd funding campaign.
Just to give you a quick
preview of how far we've come.
[ Video and Music Playing ]
So, is as what has been shared
since the last time I was here
which is just two and
half years ago.
I became National Geographic travel
year of sharing my personal story
of really looking at
the health issues
in the Afro-American community
and realizing what can we learn
when we go back to what I
call the original soul food.
African heritage foods and unlock
the secrets from those foods
and that was my last presentation
back just two years ago in 2014 here
at the Library of Congress.
And so since then between
overcoming Ebola, Boko Haram,
the presidential elections
in Nigeria I fairly made
to track this summer to Nigeria
which really prompted me creating
WANDA as a way to give back
to the community in northern
Nigeria which is heavily impacted
by malnutrition right now.
And also recognizing that we have
shared commonalities in the struggle
around good nutrition
in our communities.
It's estimated that more
than 3 billion people have low
quality diets that impacts eighteen
of the sustainable development
goals listed by the United Nations.
So, nutrition really is the heart
of our economy as well as the health
of our community and so
since then having recognized
that this double burden is not
simply just malnutrition in the form
of what we perceive it to be.
But it's also in the
form of obesity as well
in many countries including
America to Africa
and the Middle East are
facing this issue right now.
And people are asking the question,
well, how do we make ag cool again?
How do we inspire young people to go
into this sector of
food security in ag?
And so since then I had
an opportunity to go
to the African Union Summit on food
security and ag in 2014 and wrestle
with that question we had to
make a pledge how were we going
to address youth unemployment.
And I look within and
said, you know,
with the issues going on between.
As a child I did not
embrace my womanhood,
I did not embrace my heritage, I
didn't really embrace my culture
and I think that was
a survival technique.
And I think over time having
gone on to become a mother,
having gone on to realize that
yoga retreats helped as well
that everything I needed was already
within me and so from there that's
where I found the source of
inspiration of creating WANDA
because of everything
led up to that point.
So, one interesting stat that I
couldn't believe that NCD free
which is an international NGO
shared that in 2015 more people die
from heart disease,
diabetes which are known
as non-communicable diseases than
HIV, TB and malaria combined.
And these diseases
are all preventable,
it's based off lifestyle, it's
based off developmental policies
that create jobs in the
name of fast food chains
across Sub-Saharan Africa and
Northern Africa and the Middle East.
And how do we harness the potential
of the local foods, the local women
and girls to be able to
provide a better viable option
that improves the health
and the economic outlook
for these communities.
And so some of these diseases
I've already stated and the some
of the risk factors I've mentioned
as well such as unhealthy diets,
obesity as well as even gender
which we'll focus on now with WANDA.
So, when you Google black women
in agriculture and when you're try
to overcome stereotypes this is
the kind of images that pop up
and I think when we think about
people who aspire to go into sports
or music you have characters
that are portrayed
in a really bright light, right?
But when you Google things
like agriculture you
don't see positive images
and that really reminded
me why I choose not to go
in this sector even though
I grew up in Oklahoma
in a very agricultural state
cows across the street.
Is that an ag town, Stillwater,
Oklahoma and surrounded by livestock
and I wanted to get out of there
and I think a lot of people
in the room whether here again
in America or Africa head
for the city's thinking
life will be better for you.
But ultimately it is the land
that is part of our survival
and so it's taken time
for me to recognize
that again everything being already
within me and looking at, well,
how do we retell the story
through imagery, through narrative.
And so I looked at these little
girls, the first is my daughter Ruby
and how does my daughter's
generation have positive role models
in images and narratives
that inspire them to want
to be these food sheroes
in their community.
And, you know, a lot goes to
dynamic women like Michelle Obama
who has inspired a generation and
thinking about how do we continue
to hold that torch up even after
she leaves the administration.
And so the other two little girls
that I highlight is Hailey Thomas,
who's a vegan chef, not even a
teen and then we had Michaela Omar
who wrote this multimillion dollar
contract deal with Whole Foods,
with her grandma's recipe in
selling sweet pea lemonade.
Phenomenal little girls and this is
what we need for our communities,
healthy food, entrepreneurs who are
looking within themselves and being
that source of inspiration
for not only their generation
but really adults as well.
And so I took time to
put this collage together
because I asked one
friend the question about,
can we remember anyone before the
civil rights movement that was known
as a food fighter, a female
food fighter for our community?
I can only come up with anything and
so I realized it is only until now
that we start identifying and
start collecting the history
and documenting women
in food movements
and how that's another form
of owning your feminine power
and being able to turn that
narrative of back in the 60s
with the whole liberation
in 70s that I was that kid
who got a congressional
nomination for West Point.
I wanted to hightail it
again out of Oklahoma
and I did not see anything related
to gender being a positive thing.
And so it has taken time to really,
in therapy, to really recognize
that again we need new images
to inspire us to go blaze trails
in a sector that has not
been in that positive light.
Because home economics most times
we can acknowledge that we thought,
you know, who wants to be
Susie homemaker, right?
That's not a part of the
movement for liberation for women
but I now being a mom
have realized that is
where the power was,
is in the kitchen.
And realizing that women
have provide the first foods
for the babies, they are the first
in the markets selling the foods,
working the farms in many
countries and just owning again
that intersection of women,
food and power in a dynamic way
that wasn't really told before.
But something that we needed to
escape from but really that's
where the power is again now.
And so for me it's been how do we
share the story of these big WANDAs
to inspire the little
WANDAs in our community?
And so that meant coming
up with new imagery,
the women you see here are part
of WANDA either as a volunteer
or a board member representing
Ghana, Nigeria, Kenya, Eritrea,
Jamaica, America and we need
to have again new imagery
that inspires a new generation.
And so that means also
providing mentorship
and service learning
opportunities and being able
to create a safe space for
women to be able to be that full
that food sheroes that they want
to be that they never thought
that they could exchange between
geographies, generations and sectors
to really help be that source of
inspiration for their community.
And so this is me and my
daughter, Ruby, and I truly believe
in this idea that when
you empower women
and girls you nourish the world.
And the thing is for
us to own that power
as women again becomes
really important a part
of that inspiration.
And this is my son, Elliot,
he didn't really feel
that he had a role to play
in WANDA but I had and a lot
of men were asking, where is MANDA?
I was like what, MANDA,
what do you mean MANDA?
I'm like there go, there they go,
was like why can't you just
embrace WANDA and be there for us
and so the reality is I knew
that that conversation will come,
and I simply ask men,
do you have a mother?
Do you have a daughter?
Do you have a niece?
Do you have a loved one who happens
to be female that you believe that,
if given the opportunity, that
she could make a difference
in her community?
And when they begin
reflecting on that question
and realize the hard labor
that the mothers have gone
through as either single mothers
or had to be doing everything even
if they did have a husband,
they realize like wow, yeah,
my mom deserved to be more than what
she was in her life and I looked
at my own mother doing
the same thing.
They make sacrifices for us,
that's what they do and I think
if we just realized that as men they
become gate openers of opportunities
and little boys as the same way
I can count the number of stories
of men who've have already
made a difference for WANDA.
And so this is a space that, again,
we have half of the population
in DC alone, alone in the world are
women and so there is a strong stack
that if you want to overcome poverty
in the world you empower the
women and the girls to do so.
And so everyone has a
role in supporting WANDA.
So, Dangote of Dangote Foundation
in Nigeria made a great quote about
"I believe the single most important
intervention I can support is better
nutrition in Nigeria" and that is
definitely the truth given the fact
that it has some of the toughest
nutrition challenges right now
facing the continent.
And it becomes really a prized
opportunity to be that model
for everyone else in the
continent and really the world.
And so when we inspire
women and girls it means
about having stakeholders, people
beyond just the gender sector
or nutrition sector but law and
media and economics and investments.
Everyone plays a role in creating
a new pipeline of opportunity
and little WANDA really is just
that Smokey the Bear that champion,
who is tooting the horn
along the way of making sure
that everyone creates the village
that surrounds her and supports her
in providing those opportunities.
And so in doing so what we
do we educate, we advocate
and we innovate meaning
that it is not simply enough
to provide nutrition, education but
nutrition, education that speaks
of their cultural food ways.
And understanding that those food
ways have not been documented
in a substantial way
on the continent;
a lot of the nutrition
books are coming
from America, from
India, from the UK.
But again how are we documenting the
knowledge of the nutritional value
of these foods and making sure that
not only are the future nutritionist
on the continent is getting that
information but also those who serve
after the immigrant community here
in the US and in Europe as well.
And using technology
to fuel that scale
and impact becomes really important.
We were just at Microsoft
winner just this past weekend
and using the artificial
intelligence and being able
to create instant messaging for
people that ask questions related
to food resources in
their community.
It becomes a real key opportunity
to see the intersectionality
of technologies to drive
the change that we need.
And so in visiting Nigeria
and in sharing little WANDA,
I went to a Steam International
in Abuja and the kids are awesome.
Ramatu Saani is the
head schoolmaster there
and the girls had phenomenal
questions
from diabetes to gluten-free issues.
And wondering can they tune
into little WANDA on Saturday
as a cartoon and it just gave me
new ideas about what can we do
in providing a creative educational
but entertaining narrative for them
to use storytelling as a means
of educating them in a way
that they really grasp
the information.
It's not simply enough to spit out
a lecture but putting and packaging
in a way that has a gender lens, a
cultural lens is really important
and lies at the heart of how
we develop our programing
for little WANDA and the
Where's WANDA series.
And so in visiting one of
the parents who's a dietician
at the local hospital in Abuja, she
shared how they're using local foods
from cinnamon to garlic to turmeric
to cloves to tamarind as a means
of providing a nutritional
prescriptions to their patients.
And she was saying malnutrition in
the pediatric unit is not as high
of an issue as diabetes
is rising there.
And so that was very telling
about what needs to happen
and shifting our focus in preparing
for a healthier workforce
tackling NCDs.
And so that means how are we
preparing the next leaders
to be able to understand nutrition
whether they're in medicine
or pharmacy or whether they
are community health workers.
Everyone needs to be able to embrace
nutrition and little WANDA helps
to champion that and make
that intersectionality
to inspire the next generation.
And systems changes is with
that from looking at it,
from a healthcare lens we see farm
farmers rating incorporating their
food products within the hospitals.
We also see that with the cultural
lens of meeting to make sure
that we have the cultural foods
available that it's not enough just
to say that we have farmers' markets
but how those farmers
markets providing foods
that are culturally
relevant to that community.
And everyone plays a role as I was
sharing in terms of stakeholders
from those in government to
those who are family and friends
and sharing resources
among ourselves.
But most of all I find that
is the self-talk that we say
to our ourselves of saying
that well am I able to be
that food shero in my community?
And what you say to yourself
matters in making that first step
to creating the change
that you need.
And so this is the dietician
at the Abuja hospital
that I was referring to.
A lot of the hospitals have
about three dieticians,
they're busy round-the-clock, they
take calls even on their cell phones
when they're even at
home and so a lot
of the information is not documented
when they provide patient education.
And so that's another opportunity
of how do we start creating
nutritional educational materials
that is culturally
relevant, that is factored in.
There are local food
ways and also the fact
that there is a nutrition transition
happening in the community
with the new soft minerals
which we call soda here
and the Indomie [phonetic] noodles
that we call Ramen noodles here.
All of this is also
changing the food patterns
and also the health
outcomes for the community
that has to be factored in.
And so I had the opportunity to
visit one of the IDP camps in Abuja
and Moringa was growing in the camp.
Many of the folks where coming from
the north where they were farmers
but had to flee because
of Boko Haram.
And so in providing again
educational materials
that can benefit Africa and
the Diaspora our creative team
out of Lagos help to create
these informatics materials
such as Mama Moringa.
I provided the content and they
provided the creative design
about how do we start
talking about the local foods.
We call them super foods here
once they come to America
but these are readily
available, low-cost,
health options available
already in these communities,
but they simply may not
know the nutritional value
of what they have already
within their own community.
And so it becomes really important
of how can we start providing
cultural-based nutrition information
and a character that can help
provide that championship
that these little foods
need, these local food needs.
And so these are some of the women,
that Ramatu, our other board member
with WANDA helps to
bring together the...
It's a coalition of Muslim women who
assist with the IDP camp in Abuja
and I had seen a child
eating dry Ramen noodles
and it was pretty alarming
as a nutritionist to see that
and I said we cannot leave
without providing a proper meal.
And so we, you know,
took some of the funds
from the crowd funding campaign
and provided a meal for everyone.
And it was really beautiful down
to the jollof rice to the oranges,
the bananas, the water with
chicken and vegetables in the meal.
And you know it was a hot proper
meal that we also provided
through a local caterer and so
to me compared to the Plumpy'Nuts
that are provided to address
severe malnutrition I acknowledge
that that is a different status.
But if we can do things in a way
that helps build the local economy
and also introduces the local
foods that is a win-win situation
for everyone in my opinion.
And so creating healthy
eaters is the other part
that little WANDA champions.
One of the professors
out of Nigeria said
that the Nigeria soft drinks have
been shown to be high in sucrose,
fructose which are much higher
than the brands in South Africa.
And already in South Africa
more than seventy percent
of the population is
either overweight or obese,
and that's really problematic when
we think about the projected number
of 42 million is to have
diabetes by 2030 on the continent.
So, what is the intervention
that will happen?
Who will be that food
shero in the community
to help turn these numbers around,
that's the question that we ask.
And again the Trojan horse is
in the name of job development,
bringing fast food
into the countries.
Case in point, when I was in South
Africa last year the local KFC was
open for breakfast and they had
motorbikes to transport your food
and they were open around-the-clock.
We don't even have that here.
So I was like oh my God
that's like a real issue
and so I thought again how
do we compete again a David
Goliath battle?
And really little WANDA competing
in the David Goliath battle
between these large multinationals
and...and how can they actually
start directing resources in a way
that supports the local food
economy in a meaningful way.
And so again the education
in going to the camps,
going to the universities and the
schools, meeting with the parents,
doing teacher training workshops,
providing information on millet.
We have here in Tiger nuts,
they were just very impressed
and they were like the nutritional
value of their local foods to know
that they can help tackle different
disease states and they're low cost
and available on the street
easily just for a few Naira.
I think that was very powerful
for them to able to recognize it.
In millet, one of the, it's about
Nigeria's one of top producers
of millet commonly found
in northern Nigeria
where you can make the
Flo donono [phonetic]
which is a milk millet
dish available either
in the Ruger [assumed spelling]
which is the village or also
through one of the well-known
chains Habib's yogurt.
It's a very nutritious drink and
when we think about, you know,
consuming this particular
product it actually has a lot
of pre and probiotics.
Tiger nut definitely has prebiotics
and so when we're thinking
about the new frontiers such
as the microflora of the gut.
Having foods that help
provide healthy bacteria
in the gut becomes really important
and these two foods help to do that.
And so in introducing the story,
I have a copy of one of the books
that we had prepared in
Nigeria and I just want
to share the opening letter that
we provide to the little WANDAs.
We say the Where's WANDA series
is made especially for you,
we need superfood sheroes who
will help our community heal
with our heritage foods and
that's why little WANDA matters
to find the healing and
beauty of African Foods
to nourish our community.
And through her travels in Africa,
little WANDA meets female farmers
also known as big WANDAs who grow
and share African heritage foods
to feed and heal her people
in Africa and the Diaspora.
And as part of the WANDAs wisdom,
you realize that all we
need is already within us
and we hope you'll enjoy
the story and share
with your family and friends.
And most of all being inspired
to celebrate your heritage
and learn and prepare the foods.
And so with every story we actually
highlight a real female farmer
and a little girl and so we took
the journey to Kano Nigeria to meet
with Salama Togarber who runs WFAN
which is the Women Farmers
Advancement Network.
She is by far a great example
of what a WANDA woman is.
She runs a women's cooperative, they
make their own Made in Nigeria rice.
They also produce groundnut
oil; they also produce kulikuli
which is made of groundnut.
Think about peanut butter cookies
before it had white sugar in it,
that's what the kulikuli is.
And so it was just fascinating
and phenomenal to be greeted
by just a room, outdoor room full
of women bringing, who were happy
to first be graduating
through a training program
that WFAN was having.
But also unveiling their new rice
product that they've been making
for Nigeria, and so little WANDA
who in this story I
highlight my daughter Ruby.
Part of every story is about how
do we take a different woman story
and turn it into a children's book,
and so this first story really is
about my journey of finding my
heritage in Nigeria and being able
to capture my story of my grandma
having diabetes and my curiosity
as a kid wanting to know the
answer on how to help heal her.
And my father who passed
coming to my dreams
to tell me what the secret was
which was everything I needed
was already within our heritage.
And so I turned that into
a storybook and the idea is
that every book hops to a different
country being either Kenya or Benin
or South Africa and highlight who
are those champions on the ground?
What are their local foods?
And how can the help not
only their communities
but really our communities
everywhere?
And so in the first
opening we have little WANDA
who she's always curious
wanting to know what's going on
and so she eavesdrops because
that's what she does, nosy,
and she wants to know what's grandma
or Nana and her mom talking about.
And so in designing the
characters I went back and forth
with the designer but I wanted
to have relatable characters
that people can say, hey,
that looks like my Nana.
And it was important for me that
little WANDA had a little Afro
with the whole big care natural
hair movement and again realizing
that that wasn't something
that I easily would've
done back in Oklahoma.
I would straighten my hair
the moment I got off the plane
but embracing again all
that are ready have within.
And so the pictures on the back
of her uncles who she later goes
to visit and she overhears
her mom talking to Nana
that she had just came
from the hospital
and had learned that
she has diabetes.
And so WANDA didn't know what to
do about this and so she thought
about how did we get to this
place and she started to think
because she's very cerebral.
She was thinking about all of the
different foods Nana has been eating
down to the soda and down to
the cakes and the pastries
and it reminded my grandma.
My grandma loves going to
Brahm's dairy store in Oklahoma
and every time I knew she always has
some kind of sweet around the house
and she was always
offering that to us as well.
And at that time I didn't
have a clue about nutrition,
I didn't even know it
was a field at the time
and so I'm enjoying the
sweets just with my Nana
because that's what we did together.
Not realizing that, you
know, perhaps they contribute
to her complications of
diabetes in her dying later
and for me it was a moment
of being able to share
that through the magic
apron that WANDA gets
which is her great Nana's apron
that she finds in her trunk
that this becomes her way to
travel and to be on a journey
and explore how can I find
a cure for Nana's diabetes?
And so the father actually
looks like my dad
and I thought it was really
important to have the visuals
that come to mind like Africa in the
backdrop versus the princess theme
that the designer first
one is like, no.
And I thought about how important
dreams are and how, you know.
There is a beautiful story
over at the American Indian
Museum called the Little Boy
and Seven Grandfathers and the
power of dreams become opportunities
of where you actually
find the answer,
that's when spirit speaks to you.
And so it was so important for
me to capture that in the story
about the power of spirit as
another form of communication
and as a way to unlock the answer.
It wasn't something
that could happen
in the daytime only unless
she's in a meditative state
and so dreaming it's kind of
like that same meditative state
that I was capturing through
the story with the communication
that was happening between
her late father who died
and talking to her in her dream.
And so when she puts on her
apron she is able to travel
to different countries and so
she travels to Northern Nigeria
where she is greeted by two
gentlemen Ashru and Yussif
who are real friends of mine who've
helped me to travel to Nigeria.
And I asked them how do I get
the secret for Nana and we go
on this journey exploring parts
of Africa, parts of Nigeria
and they were like I know
who you need to meet,
big WANDA who is also known as Mrs.
Garba who I later met this summer.
And so through that conversation
of being with big WANDA,
little WANDA learns about
different foods such as millets
and in the book we actually have
characters for all the foods.
So in this case, she needs
Mamadou Millet and she learns
about the power of millet and
how to prepare the dish in order
to feed that to her family.
And it was so important that
the farmer looked as gorgeous
as Mrs. Garba did when I met
her and contrast the imagery
that I showed you when you Google.
Because again, we want
to show empowering images
of women embracing their foods
and becoming stewards of healing
and health and unity
that our community needs.
And so for me I would want
to be like a big WANDA
like Mrs. Garba after meeting her.
So, I just wanted to just end
and share how important it is
that we have positive
narratives for our children.
When I think about the
characters that we have now
like Ronald McDonald who
promotes, yeah, another choice
of foods I wanted little
WANDA to be in that dynamic
of David and Goliath battle.
You can give with this or
you can't give with that
but little WANDA's where it's at.
And it's really important
that we have characters
that represent our children who are
to be the future food
sheroes of our communities.
And so I just want to thank
everyone who's come out for those
who are interested in that Where's
WANDA book series we will be having
those books available
online and also for November
which is diabetes month is
when we'll have another
book signing opportunity.
So I just want to thank
the Library of Congress
for having WANDA here today
and I'm open for any questions
that you may have as well.
[ Audience Clapping ]
>> Eve Ferguson: So now you
all kind of see what I mean
about being dynamic but I'm going
to jump in front of everybody
and then we'll take couple of
questions to ask a question
about I hear little WANDA is going
Sweden where she would be talking
to the Somali community there
about some of the Somali things
that make your some [inaudible].
>> Tambra Raye Stevenson:
So the beauty of WANDA,
we're building this really
first-ever pan-African women's
network from farm to fork so we
have WANDA board members in Sweden
and in Ghana, here in
America and other countries.
And so we were invited once
learning about WANDA to come there
to recognize world childhood
obesity day is October 10th.
And so it was an opportunity for
us to help facilitate a workshop
on the migration and the
food environment and how does
that impact childhood obesity.
And so we will be at Upsala Health
Summit being able to share the story
of WANDA and how do we connect
African Diasporan women in Europe
to this movement and
become the champions
that our communities
need there as well.
>> Eve Ferguson: Okay, so
can we take some questions
to the front, okay.
Janet.
>> Great. Personally I'll
just sail through all.
Food is a global issue, on mind,
body, spirit, everything is related
to what is within our bodies so I'm
really proud of what you're doing.
I have worked in the health
food industry and very much want
to support your cause as well.
I work in media and I will
definitely be getting work
out on this.
>> Whatever I mention is my son,
I'm so proud of him,
seventeen years old.
He wants to go into
the food industry,
he can't go [inaudible]
he is also concerned
about nutrition and
I think he would be.
He actually works at KFC currently,
he's probably not [inaudible].
He's also looking for
[inaudible] family business,
an African food business.
Regarding the multinational
business is likely KFC,
I know they can vary their menu.
>> Tambra Raye Stevenson: Yes.
>> I think it's important to be
advocates and suggesting some meal,
you know, selection [inaudible].
It's just, you know, for
[inaudible] that work you're doing.
We got do in it another way or.
Tambra Raye Stevenson: Yeah,
it definitely can happen
in both directions, you know, having
worked for commerce department,
recognizing that we want to support
local small businesses and I'm now
on the DC food policy Council where
we're supporting local food economy.
It's definitely coming
in at both angles
on how do we support the small
businesses in the community
that makes up majority of
the business in America
and really across the world.
And at the same time how do
multinationals do a better job
of providing a range of healthier
options and many of them are having
to do that just on
a competitive edge.
We see what's happening
with McDonalds right now,
many of their shops are being
closed and I formally worked there.
That was my first job actually
in high school and so because of
that I've been able to recognize
that we all have to play a role
in supporting little WANDA.
Because along her journey she
may get tired and she wants
to grab something what are healthier
options for her along the way.
And so that's everything for
big WANDA to big corporation.
They all play a part in her
nutritional status for sure.
>> Thank you so much.
>> Tambra Raye Stevenson: Yes.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: [Inaudible]
want to learn the [inaudible].
I want to ask you about the
individual items; so for example,
I could not pay what
farmers are doing nobody
because for example here may not be
so easily available
like say DC or Oklahoma.
But they may have other
[inaudible] maybe,
it could be [inaudible],
it could be [inaudible].
So are you suggesting that
certain foods be incorporated
in a general diet or I think
that locally grown foods [inaudible]
should be the dominant for any diet.
>> Tambra Raye Stevenson:
So for instance millet,
sorghum they actually are
being grown in the Midwest
and there are more ethnic
crops like African Western,
African vegetables being
grown locally as well.
So part of it is, yes, number one
how do we cultivate those ethnic
crops, USD runs the ethnic
crop block rate program
and those foods are being grown
here locally in the DMV area.
And at the same time those
foods are being exported
out of the continent here as well
just packaged as superfoods and so
for me the conversation
about ethnic foods.
I think taking a visit to Ellis
Island is a very fascinating
because it just shows how
foods it seemed very exotic
at one point are so
normalized now on.
And I think that's kind of
the frontier we're heading
when it comes to African foods.
It really is when we
think about just
from the economic development lens,
what is happening globally we've
gone from Latin America to Asia
and so really Africa
now is the next frontier
over the next 50 years
even documented
by the World Economic Forum.
So you're going to see
that that transition happen
in more investments in
the gastronomic landscape
of African foods and
that will be reflected
in the speciality food
markets space.
When I go on food show visits
and hopefully, you know,
when I see these shows, you know,
it's like Italy looks
like a food mafia.
And hopefully over time Africa
is not the size of Gambian,
in these food shows in
that it does explode
and there are more local food
entrepreneurs in that space as well.
>> Eve Ferguson: I
did want to just add
that I actually met Tambra walking
across the field with a basket full
of African vegetables
grown in the United States.
And she gave me a couple and
said go home and try them
like it was gardner [phonetic].
>> Tamba Raye Stevenson: Yes.
>> Eve Ferguson: Gardner
[phonetic] and some little.
>> Tamba Raye Stevenson: Cheap leaf.
>> Eve Ferguson: Yeah and I
went home and cooked them all.
They were delicious, you can get
millet and yes Whole Foods go
to the bulk things, you can get your
own millet, I grew up eating millet
in East Africa and I
like to eat it now.
So you don't have to wait
for it to come and sell you,
you just have to seek it out.
And previously Tambra has given us
some information about the programs
that seek to grow African
vegetables.
I know they have amaranth; amaranth
is a grain I think they're trying
to go grow teff in the
United States now too.
>> Tamba Raye Stevenson: Yes,
so there's local farmers here
and that's part of WANDA.
We try to...I operate kind of
like a talent scout at this point.
Identifying what WANDA women are out
there who are doing dynamic things
that really most people
don't even know about.
We have Gail Taylor who
has a CSA right here in DC,
where she's growing ethnic crops.
We have Yall Gidisi
[assumed spelling]
who is growing ethnic crops and
they're expanding what the work
that they're doing as well you.
>> [Inaudible] production of
foods that someone wants to grow
and grow here in the United
States and you also talk
about Monsanto and [inaudible].
>> The GMO food?
>> No, [inaudible] I'm not talking
[inaudible] the genetically modified
food [inaudible].
>> You sure that.
>> [Inaudible] and so they're
introducing other seeds
from other parts of the world.
Just be aware of that danger,
that, we could be [inaudible].
And there's some recent
[inaudible] plans to bring
and destruct [inaudible] Monsanto.
And they continue to
grow [inaudible]
that their seeds [inaudible].
The argument that [inaudible].
So you have to be aware and
everyone has to be aware
of that danger, the dangerous.
>> Eve Ferguson: You know I want
to add one thing and that is
that when you reference the
drug companies, the companies is
like Pfizer and Lilly
are all over Madagascar
in the rain forest taking the
natural medicines that you can find
in the rainforest and pulling,
identifying their chemical compounds
and creating the chemical compound.
They are not only clearing out
the rain forest in Madagascar
which is a problem for the people
who've lived there and depend on it,
but they are creating
synthetic versions
of what you can get naturally.
So, people need to do their
research about what they are eating.
Some people think tofu
food is great,
tofu was genetically
modified and highly processed.
You really have to do your
research on your food.
I know, I see a big WANDA here,
there's a big WANDA back...
How many big WANDAs are here?
That's great.
I'm going to call myself a big
WANDA now because I grow food
in my backyard and I eat it.
So last night I made something with
turmeric roots, ginger, lemongrass
and the peppers out of mine and
tomatoes are out of my garden.
Those are some of the things you
can do to know where your food comes
from because you grow it.
>> Tambra Raye Stevenson:
So I do want to give a shout
out to Lolo [assumed
spelling] who is on our board.
She's in the back from
Acts Accountability
which has been behind the US
movement of bring back our girls
and also Miss Africa USA,
Francis Aduko is here as well
who also is a new founder of an
NGO empowering girls in Nigeria.
And so I just want to
thank them for being there.
>> Eve Ferguson: Can you stand up?
>> Tambra Raye Stevenson: Yes.
Can you please stand
to be acknowledged,
so now [inaudible] is in the house.
[ Audience Clapping ]
And so we were all just last week
at the United Nations General
Assembly meetings and so it's
so important to have our generation
be a part of the leadership
that our community needs
and being able to speak out
and be a voice to the issues.
Because when we look at the issue of
intersectionality of not just women
in America but black
women, African women,
the numbers change drastically
about health and economic outcomes.
And so having the voice of
those women who are tend
to be marginalized in the media
and in these larger conversations
becomes really important.
And for me even down to little
black girls having a voice
as well becomes really
important of what are their needs
and so that's why little
WANDA is so vitally important
to give a positive image
for our girls to say, hey,
I can be a change maker in my
community, food can be a healing
and an empowering way to do so.
And I'm going to do that with little
WANDA because I am little WANDA.
So thank you so much and I hope that
you join us in the conference room
for more conversations and snacks.
>> Eve Ferguson: And healthy snacks.
>> Tambra Raye Stevenson.
Yes.
>> Eve Ferguson: Healthy snacks.
Thank you very much for coming.
And you can just make your
way to the conference room.
I will go round open up the side
door and enjoy some healthy snacks.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC dot gov.